so anyway start take one well I wouldn't
recommend me driving a car right now but
I'm feeling pretty good I'm pretty drunk
right now I just want to say I haven't
drank in a long time this is mom juice
mama juice and especially proud of that
but it's the truth my pee attrition told
me that during I PA the helps with their
milk production in your boobs
it is super weird to have a baby inside
you that's the weirdest [ __ ] that
anybody can ever deal with every
pregnancy is kind of a nightmare and
people don't really talk about that set
you [ __ ] yourself you piss yourself is
blood and there was this perfect little
child that came out of all of it and it
was amazing she came out and fast she
was the most beautiful thing I've ever
seen in my life and then I look back
like recently I looked pictures of her
when she was a baby was like hey look
like an old man I don't care I love her
so much she looks like an old man I
don't care love her so much I'm very
proud of her and that she accomplished
everything that she wanted to accomplish
she she's like my purpose and she's my
girl I love her I love when she puts her
tiny little hand against my cheek and
says mommy I love you and then we close
her eyes and take a nap and then the
next thing that happens is she shoves a
[ __ ] finger up my nose I don't even
know what I used to spend money on
before I had a kid like what you can do
with your money if you don't have kids
so much gray hair now are you so like a
freedom to do things that I wouldn't do
if it wasn't for Sesame Street I
wouldn't take a [ __ ] by myself I am
sometimes not included and a lot of her
friend activity I want to go everywhere
I mean I feel like I'm young
I feel I should be in my 20s again I
feel that I should be welcome no matter
where she goes I mean there's so much
crazy [ __ ] about being a parent but also
it shifts your focus from yourself on to
this other little person everything like
all my fun stuff I used to do nothing I
mean this nothing compares to my sweet
girl I you know I don't want to be like
a cool mom um like a Regina George cool
mom I want to be a good mom of course I
want to be a cool mom you know what she
[ __ ] shoots herself in all the places
that are the most inappropriate I'm
sorry if I seem cool or uncool I don't
care but you know what first of all
there are rules and boundaries but and
I'm gonna try to say yes in the best way
so you know what you don't want your
avocado here have a turkey burger
instead my soft UI can I say kids are
awesome and I think that being pregnant
can be really really scary but I want
you to know that it's gonna be okay your
kid is gonna be cool and if they're not
cool it's your fault I want to be a good
example for her tonight but might not be
the best night good thing she's sleeping
right I'm going to the clubs next I'd
I'd be more fun is that a gay bar all
right I don't do this often I just it's
a special occasion it's a special
occasion this is what you do in LA you
told me you go to brunch if the dog at a
to me it's just what you do let's see
Feeny was he busy [ __ ] feet busy busy I
see busy buzzy fifa's bees buzzy feet
was eating buzz-buzz something I like to
cut my bangs after two glasses of wine I
don't really recommend it but don't
always cut your bangs after two glasses
of wine cuz it could be crooked but my
turned out okay right there straight